hello and welcome to this video this is
coverage for round six of the candidates
tournament yeah and this is going to be
a difficult video I can tell you that
right away because of a particular
problem this round was the most
interesting round but it also will be
difficult to yeah somehow get this into
a video of normal normal length and I
would have to cut some corners down but
we'll see what happens okay i'm starting
with um no actually want to side with
that one yeah kawana kayaking yeah this
is a game where karana needs to try to
win now he's got fifty percent or
drawers and he had good positions or
winning positions for example against
Apollo okay I can is sitting very nicely
there on this plus to score yeah we'll
see what happened in the game not
surprisingly we get the Queen's in yet
again the opening all the tournament so
far and Jan fact we follow an earlier
game this is the same position as
happened again am in top I love kayaking
has happened to Paul of kayaking and now
corona comes up with a new movie place a
three instead of two part of droopy one
the idea is similar to go not this it be
32 before so a black fields that before
as a strategic threat and go see five
and we get the same hanging porn
position yeah as mentioned this is a
clear on this game is again clear
evidence that the Queen's Indian can
lead to interesting play yeah here it
seems that yeah this huge tension in the
center will you will need to direct
complication so interesting move now is
not c4 note that if white takes on
595 night f7 we've seen similar ideas in
them to paula kayaking game this is not
just so great here check as black is not
losing material directly look you've won
at night and six um yeah this was played
interesting move um using this pin on
the diagonal the night has two ideas it
can go to e3 in some cases to intensify
the pressure here or after 9 p-6 can
jump to a five interesting idea yeah
after Bishop a six now Corona played the
move before yeah this is a very
interesting move the ideas to gain some
strategic advantages here if the sea
pawn moves then white gets the default
square if we start to look at let's
start with this month yeah it's really
bad but just have a look B 596 a for
whether it's absolutely terrible so
advancing was no option at all yeah a
black could have played some move like
27 there was nothing obviously wrong
with it but okay I can decided to take
this pawn this is a risky decision in
some way after wyd recaptured um he
still had an option to play let's say
normal chess with rook c8 the text the
night and something like be five Brooks
is read and be a six and Queen d7 does
not have to be bad for black white has
got the bishop pair but it's not clear
that this is a big issue for black what
he did is
very debatable yeah it maybe shows that
hurricane is absolutely confident in
this tournament that his decisions are
correct it takes take some bravery to
play that now he took on before and yeah
why is that such a brave decision you
have to have a look yourself after 96
this is a fork and this is also attacked
so did he blundered no he didn't he
actually yeah now sacrifice his queen he
took on c3 night takes 28 and Bishop
takes me to that was kayaking lence idea
and he thought that it leads to a
position that he can defend yeah and it
holds relatively comfortably him if I
believe he he said if I read that some
way I'm not quite sure if I'm reading so
much about this event and different
sources so I cannot really sometimes
tell where I read what but it seems that
he said that he felt it should be pretty
okay for him and no big problems which I
mean it shows the confidence yeah let's
have a look black and take one of the
rooks here rook takes rook 28 yeah and
now we can can take stock maybe it and
do that after UK 7 so black has got a
roof and a minor piece and the depot for
the Queen that is not so bad but it is
it certainly it's it's borderline yeah
and it depends a lot on the specifics of
the position what is good for black is
that he doesn't have any particular
greet pneus in terms of pawn structure
around the king so this this is fairly
solid also there d porn gives some clear
counterplay that's also very important
that you have an idea to do something
actively yourself of course you can
sometimes who would those positions with
the pure fortress but it's good to her
something that you can use fact of play
yeah I think the next moves are fairly
logical night comes to see for the
bishop God reroute to to g6 yeah now
this happened and G for me yeah and this
position is very interesting to look at
if you give this to to an engine it
doesn't matter which one they all give
white a winning advantage or close to
that yeah 1.3 1.4 basically a win it's
however not so clear at all how that
wind should should happen because still
black and hold his weaknesses pretty
well and there is no clear way of making
any progress in the game um kayaking
play King g7 and now Queen to see three
that looks entirely normal yeah trying
to get the Queen to d4 and maybe
initiate something against f6 however
now kayaking places trump card what i
said the depart can provide counter play
here we go and the d porn is going
forward i think if anything here maybe
if Kara wanna can can improve or could
have improved on his play he played a g5
now but maybe Bishop f three years
giving more chances in the game we see
that the opening of the G file actually
helped black but it is very difficult to
to see that beforehand if if if at all
possible um something like d2 King up
and d1 Queen something like that is
probably probably going to happen and
still absolutely not clear to me if this
can be one or not I mean they're
definitely winning chances and white can
try forever and ever but are you really
winning hmm not sure not sure at all I
mean a black has aged 6 to make sure
that the Jeep on can also easily advance
and he has to cover f6 yeah like with
the rook here and look here yeah it
depends there at various possible
fortresses but I think still draw is the
favorite here yeah but white can try the
way it went it was a direct draw
surprisingly g5 as mentioned was played
d to Jack and black went into the corner
yeah and now we see the issues here why
does just in time to stop the deep on
yesterday that of course and now here's
the big point black has this tactic
tactic you know take together strong
word but he can try to distract that
bishop and promote the default deep on
let's say completely yeah then why
doesn't even they will to up to
sacrifice for it yeah and now it gets
very tricky he played this note that
after Bishop g4 black hats the fantastic
Luke g8 and again threatens to promote I
cannot be stopped actually what else
yeah why I definitely shouldn't take
yeah this is something that should be
avoided check when TM black will
probably win you as white has two sec
the Queen tricky business yeah and King
edge to was played by Caruana and now
it's a draw that means of bishop t5
again a nice little tactical IDM and
Brooke g8 yeah and here White has to
force a draw
and this is possible with the move
Bishop to d1 yeah blocking the pond and
after takes takes white now is in time
to always catch this pawn after age six
they agree to a draw yet again somewhat
disappointing result for Caruana he had
very good positions in the event winning
positions at times against the parlor
for example it was a pretty simple win
for a player of that that level and here
again if anybody had chances it was of
course wide but it was very difficult to
do something with that with that Queen
against rook piece and pawn there wasn't
a clear way probably to win even though
it it certainly leaves a feeling of
probably dissatisfaction that you could
cannot do anything even here the
opponent very yeah it was a bit of a
reckless decision to give the Queen a it
wasn't necessary really for kayaking to
do it but it was it was possible
certainly not totally totally bad but
it's only feels bad for forms for karana
probably that the pond just could give
the Queen I could do much okay anyway in
the next game I want to check us to Palo
giving and do we get a group felt no we
don't get it wound fell because not a
pile of places to move age for this is
certainly the move of the tournament so
far for being the most outrageous
decision probably um yeah that's a that
move recently was seen in a grandmaster
game by a strong lacanian ukrainian
grandmaster coral buff and it also has
been played a couple of times as i read
somewhere by english GM Sande Williams
was very much known for
aggressive playing style I don't think
this move is any good to be honest but
there are similar things that have been
tried against the Greenfeld for example
but I played a couple of times in blitz
chess is this line and this is a think
in comparison are not better because
here black has already committed to that
kind of setup you know how the center
looks like so you know if an H pawn move
can be can be sensible and here when
there is some point to it yeah it for
example it seems nowadays that probably
like something xe6 is the best reply if
you compare that to the actual game here
black only has started with the
fianchetto but has not set up the center
in any way so he is still he's free to
set up in any way put that he might like
and give him goes for something that
makes lots of sense he plays the banco
in a way with white having played the
booth h4 see takes b5 no played by T'Pol
off it seems that Simon Williams likes
to play h live in this position and I
have to admit that this does make more
sense to me than than what the par loved
it I mean he Williams seems to be eager
to play this and then play you for I
mean it's a total mess and I would be
very surprised if white is objectively
better but this is definitely something
that leads to totally irrational play
and white has has chances in the game
just to compare things this happened so
it was played like a regular benko it's
just that white has to move h4
yeah if we look at this position this is
just looking like a normal benko and
white has played that completely
completely pointless move age for it is
not even a loss of time it is a lot of
time but it also just Ricans wides
position so here it is just a question
can whiten hold on noise it is it really
really bad now this is the only question
here and I find it pretty amazing that
Apollo plays into that position after
nine moves where it's really just a
question how bad it is for him okay the
whole game is basically um defensive
effort by white and we'll see how it how
it turned out Bishop d3 Bishop 86 Quincy
to yeah i should mention YH for so
useless yeah you never get an attack
here with h5 and you weaken squares for
example the g four square this is
something that really makes them it is
important it's really important we see
later in the game um do i want to fast
forward i can i can go add a couple of
moosa just just to show that this is in
fact importantly this is a square that
black can sometimes use and also note
when you go h form it makes it more
difficult to play F for four examples
play f4 for example because this is
leaving so many holes yeah the point is
back on h2 you can at least imagine that
f4 could be a playable move at some
point yeah you know you notice that made
it moves a couple of moves rather
quickly yeah White has some play Bishop
g2 c3 and lost them it will bit more
time with the night yeah it just seems
to about to hold yeah he has to go
nighty to back again so that you can
actually castle let's got traded and
queen d three yeah this is some
excellent benko for black and he gets to
trade queens which is not a problem at
all or even though he is a pawn down but
it's absolutely no problem because the
pressure persists even after the Queen
trade we see right here how much
pressure there is on those pawns and
yeah this is the in the picture that you
should look at him white cannot move his
pawns this is a very strong night it can
hardly be arrested with this yeah note
that if the Pawn would be on h3 that
moves like f4 really would come into
consideration but not like this black
here has excellent pressure and he was
playing I think just a good game overall
him here f5 as a typical method to
undermine white spawns a very active
player black and ce4 yeah a typical
break what white wants to do and what
black wants to do is to trade this
against one point here to get a further
isolated pawn and yeah we got there so
Black now has a couple of pawns to
attack he can attack those three mostly
and in the game we see that he gets a
pawn back um black also around here
ranchi also could have taken on edge for
which may be was stronger but it's
difficult to decide if you have to
decide between a couple of advantageous
options it's always it's always
difficult to do we decided to play route
to a b5 and now take the pond like that
so the h-bond dropped after its early
adventure and yeah it's equal material
but white still has those weaknesses
yeah so part of forever now puts up a
very very
um tough defense check let's get traded
and he later March the a pawn of the
board he ultimately was forced to to
give that pawn because it is a weakness
it cannot be cannot be kept but it seems
that this ultimately is probably a draw
it's not much fun to play quite clearly
but it still seems to be a draw yeah the
setup is is quite resilient the King
protects the poem the night is
protecting this and the white rook is
also able to help even by offering a
rogue trade yeah and this loop trade is
what happened now I think after that
it's definitely a draw so maybe you
should have kept the rugs on but it
feels really unlikely that black can can
win there I mean the whole game was very
one-sided and blacks and blacks favor
but sometimes you just cannot win yeah
it's young it's too too sturdy yeah give
it a try for a while cannot lay hand for
multi trying but gap this is the end of
game after this this white gets the
final porn so um yeah what to make of
that game to pull off came up with this
aggressive move this age for but he was
on the defensive like three or four
moves later and I don't know something
seems off and is in his tournament h4
has already moved that looks a little
bit like frustration but it's it feels
kind of strange that when he when he
arrives at this position that he goes
then for for the passive approach now
basically by taking and playing a bank /
h 4 is really frankly ridiculous move
h5 Williams move really makes sense yeah
decentralize this is night and gains
time that makes the whole thing
completely I'm yeah rational and it's
this is interesting it's really
interesting position that you can play I
mean it's not my kind of chess but it's
definitely something that makes them
make sense to me playing what would
happen in the game is just the
transportation to a bank / H for some
garbage bid weird to put it mildly okay
let's go to the next game this is anand
with wide against Peter Svidler um we
have a rillo pass and spill the place a
sexy does not play the Berlin and yeah
it makes him a good guy in my book not
that I'm hating the opening so much but
I think when we see in the game yeah I
let the clothes Spanish and all kinds of
forms of offers more interesting play
now the first interesting moment comes
right here and spiller castles he plays
both moves he plays castles mt6 he plays
more than one line in the in the closed
he plays the brayer he plays the side
seven but he also plays the marshal and
castles signals his intention to play a
marshal I now place a form also an
interesting choice I thought that this
move was largely defined nowadays due to
be form but probably are not had
something in store there we we don't
learn that from from this game because
we got plays Bishop e7 this was them the
main line of this a 4 n time marshal
like 20 years ago when Kasparov played a
for a lot in his match against Nigel
short but it went out of fashion
um quite a while ago the main argument
against this move is that after d3 white
has this very sound porn chain and the
bishop on b7 sometimes doesn't really
have a great future there I have played
this position myself with black and I
have to what exactly is the right
expression yeah my my own my own
experience kind of confirms this that
this can be a tricky a tricky way for
black to play I mean I don't play that
move on anymore with with castles so I'm
not really getting this position again
but i would definitely I think go for
beef one set of Bishop e7 anyway this is
not bad or anything I'm just stating a
personal preference here ruki 892 Bishop
f8 an interesting move c3 and 985 ok the
ships into Bishop a2 is also possible
here but all this looks very very normal
c5 and d4 yeah white opens up the center
after all black now has some options how
to deal with this with the center he can
play d 6 however this seems to be a bit
of a wrong moment there I know that
those rouleau PES middle games they can
be very confusing because they kind of
look look the same but little details I
imported here for example after d5 those
two pieces really have the entirely
wrong positions yeah this Bishop should
be on d7 here and the night ideally
should be on a five in the first place
but it rather often is in the chagrin
but he cannot even easily regroup yeah
like c4 97-95 would be would make sense
but that's not possible him
so d6 is not good black probably should
take on deform interesting for example
here is to take with this and play d5
look sharp but after d takes Knight
takes black hair pin oak black has been
ok in in Grand Master games yeah let's
meet up place differently he takes here
with the e pawn and then goes some d5
and I don't think that this is so great
maybe it could have played this yeah II
595 it's also it also risky a little bit
yeah we already see already that white
has a couple of attacking or aggressive
looking pieces geared towards the king
but probably still nothing terrible is
happening then let's say 94 black can
can answer with the various moves he has
to watch out for peace is coming to g5
if you go aged 6 cm and queen d3 for
example yeah it was an alternative to
take them and after d5 spit let's move
it gets it gets really dangerous be 5 94
and here i don't play some a new move
ATX b5 it wasn't part of home
preparation here but it's a new move
technically there has been a game
interesting the other from 2004 between
sheer of wine and only shook black where
she replayed not sure on plates Knight
takes pawn takes rook takes e4 hmm that
looks flashy very interesting after
Bishop takes Bishop takes in fact Ruth
white is winning already the threat is
Bishop takes edge step very brutal and
also of course taking the rogue
if black moves the rock then Bishop h7
is already checked winning the game we
will see something very very similar in
the game I don't want to go through the
lights because I will show some in the
actual game continuation the funny thing
is that here black had a cool reply he
played them whose night to be three
which is a bit of a shocker yeah really
am a cool move yeah the rook is hanging
black might take here and if the bishop
takes black is happy to take the rook so
what did what did why do in this game
mmm he tried Bishop g5 yeah that that
didn't work out well he had drew cage
for okay I don't want to analyze this
game but I want to show that a very
similar idea has been played before in
the game to show what happens takes
takes Knight takes pawn takes rook takes
the same thing the same idea and now
again black can not take because he will
be killed by Bishop takes h7 we can ever
look now let's say black plays route to
a 6 to try to at least use the rook four
for defensive purposes okay then Queen
d3 probably and not the not the
sacrifice I want to this is also good
for why they're like this this is this
looks pretty awful but let's have a look
quickly at the sacrifice yeah if black
ghosts let's say he am then Bishop 87
twins Chang yeah this is answer back 93
and black has to sacrifice the Queen to
avoid the maid or alternatively if he
goes back Greenidge five is also
threatening far too much and black has
to give the Queen again so definitely
black could not take the rook yeah what
is the debt he should play it's very
difficult to say
um maybe maybe g6 is the only move that
does not lose right away it basically
says okay I'm a pawn down yeah I made a
mistake but let me just try to hang on
them being a pawn down but having active
pieces and that Bishop for example is
still an active piece that's probably
objectively the best move what he played
is 93 the same idea that that only shook
played however here now we have a big
difference and the difference is that
now the rook can actually win this
attacked it now can take and after
Bishop takes its rights move and he has
a very strong continuation what white
can play is 92 g5 and it turns out that
this is already winning for white yeah
swidler has lost here after 20 moves
yeah how does that continue he took on
c1 now took the bishop on c1 we can
check other ideas what happens if black
takes the rope that's the first thing we
can check Bishop takes e4 it's a simple
reply and now we have to note that of
course this Hanks and it just it's not
just a pawn the thread is Bishop h7 King
h8 night at seven winning the Queen and
there are also attacking ideas with
Queen h5 it's just that black now cannot
just play I don't know night XD for
something like that this this is chang
winning the Queen for the easiest line
maybe there's something more effective
but yeah sorry after Bishop takes it
basically means that black is out of out
of moves here now something like g6
queen bee three is disastrous it's from
a material point of view what is winning
but also the pure position is over like
this maybe makes very quick makes a very
quick finish yeah so black cannot take
the rook we see what happens if he takes
the bishop
see one in the game and there are really
no big alternatives IAM like age six for
example what can just take him ma this
first the idea why this material up and
attacks kings it's very very bad yeah
it's a loss it's just a loss amazing
yeah okay night xe1 was played by the
best villa queen age five threatening
checkmate always good yeah age six
chatting takes King edge eight and now
very strong move by bashir rook g-form
that's very strong the idea is that we
protect the night so that Queen takes g5
is no threat anymore and black cannot
capture of course check check check
check mate due to that made and after
looking for white is also threaten equi
ji six queen age seven yeah and it turns
out that leg is completely completely
out of moves yeah he tried Queen to a
five that's the relatively best try and
least threatening a mate yeah you can
always hope but Anna just played age
four and prevented the checkmate we can
switch i reside here let's start with
that information you could have so
played this and 92 to to continue but
why it has a very strong reply night h3
i actually think he resigned a little
bit too early it's something that I
definitely would not recommend you to do
for example if you are in a game yeah as
long as it is not totally apparent how
you're getting checkmated I
continue yeah 983 threat covers the
Queen g1 thread and here um blackest out
of moves yeah he really is lost it was
not that swindler resigned yeah it
wasn't miss evaluation it just said you
shouldn't really am yeah give the
opponent so much credit that you
resigned that early yeah how does it
continue here black legs Lucas hanging
so probably he will move the rook
somewhere and then create a five
threatening made king here and now check
check this um will ultimately lead to
defeat but you know why it's the last to
do some things in this for example check
check check yeah it does win no no
question but it was still a rather early
resignation yeah a very disappointing a
game certainly for Scylla we had a good
tournament up to that point he had in
the first five rounds he never was in in
serious um trouble at all i think but he
was well prepared and even had some
slight chances in games and so it yeah
slight chance and he probably should
have somehow won the game against in a
camera even though it's it never had a
super clear point where it was a win so
at the end now still des on minus one he
lost that game played a couple of
drawers makes it very difficult for him
to get back into contention however are
not now it's again looking very very
good there with plus one and yeah if
he's playing he's just playing bad bad
at all I mean he's he had a she had
somewhat shaky game against cocky but
doing a good job otherwise okay now
let's get to the game aronian
wrong um and this will be tricky
business I can tell you right away and
okay I have one too this game is very
long first of all it has like 80 knees
90 moves I have to check 83 yeah so um
I'm giving you an overview of the whole
game but I cannot really do every move
or move some justice here in a way so we
have this an idea where black wins upon
by the way I should mention it's again
the Queen's engine with Bishop a sexist
the tournament that the opening of the
tournament really crazy how often this
is played and it's also again the camera
playing this opening it's not part of
his regular repertoire and yeah very
surprising how it's a stubborn as the
wrong word but how faithfully is maybe
in this in this in this preparation um
yeah Quincy to an interesting reply
because after c5 white goes for the d5
move note that black we have to go back
there black cannot take this because of
Queenie for the nice little trick but
after Bishop to be seven that what's
Nakamura played the pawn is definitely
lost yeah white cannot play I mean can
play the move but it doesn't help before
also will use a pawn due to 27 this is
hanging and this is hey it's also not
the point white actually wants to
sacrifice this point so what is White's
compensation for the pawn development he
already has cancelled and he's got the
Queen out which is semi useful the queen
is not always good on c2 quite often it
will move again
we see in the game that it moves again
black is a little bit behind the
development has not cancelled yet and
has a shaky squares yeah especially d5
d6 and sometimes the poor non-disabled
can become can become targets of course
this is something that has been analyzed
for quite a while already and has yeah
gotten it has amassed some some some
real body of theory by now so it's not
something that they now work out over
the board okay castles 96 was played
rook to e1 Bishop e7 cool move why does
not threaten this because night before
is a big Fork there's also a white
ghosts create a form now attacking the
night for real which retreats and now
night to h4 typical idea in the Queen's
Indian it opens up the bishop and it
intends to switch the night over to f5
often a great attacking square
especially when there is no bishop 1c8
that is able to to to take that not yet
like after the fianchetto here it's
clear that the neuron f5 will be
difficult to expel young castles 93-95
also has been tried but 93 is a very
normal looking north of course yeah mg6
now to control at five and now Bishop g5
we see white has good development and
it's difficult for black to use his
central pawn I mean this is his extra
porn that he has but the issue is you
can vary reality and move it yeah d
sixes store live blundering a piece and
you cannot go d5 here either as it just
hangs yeah I mean something like ticks
ticks
duty 5 i'm not even sure that this is so
terrible for black but it seems a bit
wrong to give the pawn up immediately
maybe you can also take here by the way
because rook takes is actually keeping
this attack hmm yeah but do you want to
return the porn that quickly probably
not rupee 8 was played by by Nakamura
and they're covering that bishop and now
Bishop f4 c8 bishop age 6 it looks a bit
strange but white wanted to get this one
in yep the Queen on aphorism
aggressively recive Lee placed a funny
line that should be a very much note it
is if black plays the move Knight age 5
now the game would end really quickly as
actually takes f7 that's nice right
check check check check mate that's cute
yeah so night h5 is a bad idea yeah but
what should like to night to a five
looks decentralizing but it's not so bad
black also could have played Queen c7 I
should actually really tell you
something and I only today found out
that on chess com um there's a regular
um it's section the right word this a
maxi Bashir lagrave the top top French
GM and currently number C number five on
number six in the world something like
that he's um doing analysis on one game
of the round the most interesting game
and it's very extensive analysis and I
looked through that for this game and
use some of his comments so i should
actually tell you that it's um most of
what I'm
giving you now as some kind of brief
version of what he already did yeah I
looked at the game myself a little bit
but then found his analysis it's like 10
times better than mine which is not a
big hit but a big surprise so I just
should just tell you what I'm relying on
him yeah Queen c7 was a decent
alternative what I present you by the
way it's just the tip of the iceberg he
really he made them for this game it's
like six full pages in a printout so
it's really remarkable what effort he
put into that yeah Queen c7 um it's
probably okay for black after the trade
and now probably not to be five looks
like the most obvious move gaining a
tempo on the rook um look back and night
a seven this could happen but after book
cd8 everything is ok for Black now has
returned to porn but yes consolidated
it's very difficult here for black to
think about converting an extra porn
this is born to understand why it's
pressure and active pieces is so
annoying that you barely get into even
the mindset of converting a born now you
have to defend all of the time it's not
a very attractive position in my book
but something it's it is something that
you have to play and defend well it's
just that you have to be realistic here
you cannot just like win with the porn
you have to defend and see that you can
probably em yeah get into a conversion
in a very slow way it was just not just
winning with a pawn okay he played night
a five and night f5 was played and funny
idea of course this is not possible mate
next move and so Bishop g2 and now I'm
yeah Romeo to Pondi seven it was not
strictly necessary also could
plate kingi to immediately unite sue is
not hanging maybe that was a little bit
more interesting check keeping a little
bit more tension yeah now black gets 25
in and should be okay yeah III d5 Bishop
g5 and now ninety-four was played by
Nakamura the move on King g7 was also
possible and does not seem to present
any big problem yeah black ISM giving
back the d5 pawn but as I said he almost
always has to be be ready here than
return some material to make the
position completely equal and something
like this for example is some is equal
yeah 90 force plate rooty five now got
this trade sir yeah and this position is
a little bit difficult for black to play
I mean it's so not it's not terrible or
anything but it is slightly annoying
that alternative King g7 was certainly a
bit cleaner here you always have this
feeling that the night could be an issue
yeah not that it is on the rim that is
also not so great but the bishop ian in
comparison is keeping or controlling
those important squares and this feels a
bit awkward also note that this is
controlled however it seems that black
still is very very solid Nakamura is
pulling up a good defense and we can go
ahead a couple of moves I think
yeah all looks good for why but how do
you win yeah Aronian was slowly try to
improve his position yeah it's mostly
shuffling and making sure that you don't
repeat three times a form yeah and now
we come to an interesting and then an
interesting situation now camera now
play some the move 92 check and this is
a very very tough decision 92 gets into
a weekend game or offers to go into Luke
ending which an offer that was taken the
question is what's that necessary he
could have also played differently for
example he could have played night to a
three and it seems in comparison but
this is leading into leading to and more
problems than that Luke ending for
example white could try things like age
5 p.m. 9 p-5 rupee 793 and after takes
rook takes at m5 white should win it's
just this is not a totally false line
but it shows that ya going yeah long
roots here with the night for porn can
prove to be very dangerous I think and
this is also what the MDL what he gives
in his notes that getting into that rook
ending is not the worst that can happen
to black so takes takes and yeah it's
also impossible for right now to avoid
trade of another look like this this
and this gets taken NC 4 yeah this is a
the the reason why this is still
somewhat uncomfortable the c-4 pawn
stops the black be pony only six not fun
but it's it's something that is part of
playing such an event you have to be be
tough and try to defend not try but
managed to defend and some some bad
positions ok key to g7 you form and
route 38 there are alternatives yeah
almost after all every move yet but to
don't make that video at to our fam I'm
keeping this a bit a bit shortened oke
five rupee eight rue 57 threatening e6
so black has to go back and now f5 yeah
here there was an interesting
alternative in h5 yeah giving up a pawn
if black takes f5 is the idea is also by
the way this is a maneuver like that
like h5 takes an f5 is a typical example
of why rook endings are often so complex
they really offer some scope at least of
let's say creativity or some options
often in minor piece endings there is a
very clear way forward or there is a
clear way somewhat static way let's say
a setup or very yeah very narrow
approach that this has to be employed
however in rook ending sometimes you can
really choose between options passive
play sacrifice a pawn for activity
activate the king activate the rook for
material all kinds of things are
possible yeah that probably hear this
idea h5 takes
five is some very interesting but
probably probably not winning what mvl
ultimately analyzes is keen to e8 as
leading to a draw yeah what to see what
does he give Rock g6 looks very very
normal and now rook e8 is the point
quite interesting why it takes then
black activates with rogue d4 and
something like this and this check
listen this is main line into you
assesses this as ultimately okay for
black huh it's it's very tough business
it's very tough business yeah in the
game f5 was tried I think in comparison
I think it's probably they're somewhat
more yeah logical is wrong but maybe the
more apparent idea takes and king air
for the King gets activated yeah now be
five by Nakamura that was clearly need
to activate this King at five yeah and
now we come to the first um yeah
inexplicable let's say a pair of moves
in a way Nakamura now has to play um
King to e8 and this leads to some
version of the game yeah I don't want to
really show the lines um mdl analyzes
this for quite a bit but it leads to a
version let's say of the game without
giving one particular option what
nakamura plate is to move a 3 and this
should lose immediately due to King f6
and its really inexplicable by aronia
did play
after king of six black can basically
resign me the point is of course that
the check check can be answered by root
d6 and the king airport ending check is
totally unplayable s why Jim like this
this is white is getting this pot so
check black cannot take means he has to
go back but then the position is just
absolutely awful it's super passive yeah
FYI wyd can just advanced him and there
is absolutely nothing that that black
can do and what is a continuation now
Roxy either try to support the Seaport
f5 see 457 c3 check check threatening
mate check check and wide widths check
it's a win do 2222 that porn ok tf6 was
winning but Aronian didn't do that he
played a form and now the next couple of
moves I think feel rather logical we
have the whole Queen side getting traded
down as it happens both ports were going
forward and now we reach this ending
yeah three against two on one side of
the board it's not possible just from
the material account to assess what the
position is if it is a draw or a win for
white in many cases it will be a draw
three against two but there are some
specific positions that are winning for
example one very famous example of a
wind would be on the board if the white
pawn was on h form but would be on g4
this would be a structure that is well
known since the game kappa blanca with
wide against Frederick Yates from it's
the thing in late 1920s if i'm not
mistaken i could be wrong on that
account could be in the 30s hmm well
around that time um the position with
the point of g4 is wind however here
with the porn on h4 it is a draw and I
can say that with total certainty
because I read up a little bit already
today because that was a much-debated
end game today it seems that the scotch
or Danish Scotch Grandmaster Scottish am
sorry Grandmaster jakub our guard also
very well known form for his publishing
company quality chairs and his books he
put this position or this whole endgame
into am a program called final gin it is
a program that can create table bases um
and with you can give this program a
specific position and it will create a
table base with perfect play for this
position with any reason let's say if
you give it too many pieces it will take
like when I know yeah two years to
calculate and more hard drives that you
can buy but it seems that this end game
took a couple of hours overnight and it
ultimately um came back with a with a
one hundred percent certain evidence
it is a draw so this is good to know
however it's so tricky to prove i must
say that you can um you can do i can
look at many things here mdl has I think
roughly four pages on this ending and
it's I really don't know what to do with
it doing this on in the video seems kind
of seems kind of seems kind of insane
what I want you to what I want to do is
and you know it I know it is a bit
insane because someone else has already
done this and I don't want to do
something which is totally redundant in
a way i will show you some ideas
definitely but if you want to dig deep
into this ending you should look at the
notes by mvl it has been published on
chance com or you can also watch Daniel
Kings video yeah Danny King SS power
play chess channel and he did I think 15
16 17 minute video today or I mean
friday friday the 18th as i would call
this is a 19th already on this ending
that you can also watch very much
recommended um i'll show you some ideas
however so that you also have an
impression on in this video um so I'm
Roxie formers plate we can look at how
the game progressed left make sure we
have to make sure to not miss the miss
the critical point I wasn't much
happening for quite a bit check
yeah note that wise didn't get anywhere
and here in this position we have the
decisive moment of the game um yeah here
black just has to play um normal boof
let's say yeah basically anything would
do besides the one that you actually
played if you play I mean I would go
rookie to him just to yeah make sure he
six is not happening yeah it's not the
only movement and we want to look at
what nakamura did he played the move
King to have eight and there was some
kind of controversy here because it
seems that he I mean you can watch the
video yeah it's easy to watch the video
and see yourself well what happened is
he touched the king and while I mean he
didn't touch it to to adjust it yeah it
was perfectly positioned on that square
he touched the King intending to
actually move it and then when he was
trying to move the piece he recognized
that he loses immediately with King and
after King evade and then he tried to
kind of say I adjust yeah but it was
already too late he had touched the
piece and had to move it um there was
some controversy there controversy is
there that was unfair play or something
like that I think what we have to be
aware of that Nakamura this situation
yeah he wanted to move the king he
didn't want to adjust the piece and he
just at that moment had this awful kind
of realization that this is the end of
his tournament yeah King at eight meets
the tournament is over and in this in
this situation you don't think very
rationally aunty I guess automatically
try to somehow yeah talk is talk himself
out of this mess as saying I adjust this
is not I mean yeah you can certainly
behave more
yeah here maybe a handle the situation
better yeah but it's not something that
I would hold against somebody because
the pressure is immensely immensely high
and if you have this kind of area
adrenaline pumping and so on you you do
stuff that is sometimes yeah far far
worse him I mean even even in totally
unimportant games it happens if you are
in time trouble and things are heating
up you sometimes do things that don't
make much sense and you regret very
quickly I mean I've had my fair share of
blitz games that are lost idiotic Lee
Weyer set stupid things right after the
game the important thing is to kind of
realize a little bit later and say okay
I'm sorry that wasn't wasn't appropriate
and everything's good anyway what
happened is he played that King at eight
move and after King f6 it's losing
because Chang there is his route 26 move
the idea that we had seen earlier me so
let's quickly look how the game ended
and then see what he should have done
yeah now why it makes very serious and
resin check check and yes all the time
in the world now ya hear he actually the
game ended okay well it's a bit
surprised that it ended with black
smooth you usually resign instead of
playing a move in fact okay e 6 is the
thing after the take stakes why does
promoting here trades rooks with a later
later promotion let's have a look at the
alternative there it's interesting to
note that in the press conference um
let's see not this move in the press
conference aronian actually claimed that
he believed that possess position is a
draw as win anyway um it's quite funny
we not not funny because
um it is a draw we know that it is a
draw because of that computer analysis
but I also thought it was kind of kind
of beer because I felt that bye-bye all
general consideration the likelihood of
the jaw should be extremely high to be
very honest when I saw this position a
couple of moves ago lap 10 was earlier I
looked at that on my smartphone while I
was on my chess club and I basically
didn't look again until I returned home
and then saw like what that was a wide
win I was a dead wrong um okay it is not
so easy but far not so easy as I thought
but um still I was surprised that
Aronian was kind of pretty convinced
maybe that TM that he hadn't been yeah
anyway what what should like do him um I
was thinking rookie too and as I noted
there's much much more very interesting
analysis by both mvl and any King on his
channel I was thinking rookie to to
prevent e6 and to be honest I'm not
quite sure um if some positions that mvl
and can look at if they even have to
come up on the board but I'm prom name
maybe I'm just wrong I don't know I
really don't see white getting anywhere
here I mean absolutely not anywhere what
is why it's supposed to do him yeah
maybe h5 this was suggested by uronian
as a set up at least but they looked i
think at a somewhat different position i
think they actually and started when the
on move firm 62 when the end game um
yeah mos was beginning let's say but in
this specific situation i really don't
see how there's any any progress to be
made black stays here on the only file
and the white cannot play six what
exactly is the big progress here yeah
what white can try is he can try
something like rook is
trying to play six that way but then
Luke age one should work yeah a very
weird idea is that after e6 Jay takes
kiji for King f6 is a draw which is a
little bit in human i have to admit that
but it is at all yeah and if that is not
working what exactly is wise idea I mean
if white comes back we can gamine black
can also just go here what is the point
if you six is not coming you can also
check check check I really don't see
that what White's point assume check
know if what goes all the way there then
look at what is the end of game I mean I
think this is especially the position
here instead of king of a diff Black is
just staying on the e-file should looks
totally dead to me maybe earlier there
was a little bit more but still I don't
see it if you want to explore this
ending a little bit more as I mentioned
there are MBL MV else notes and also add
any kings video on his on his channel I
really cannot add much to what they
looked at then he actually looks at a
comparable a very similar end game with
some with some funny points but I don't
want to make that video much longer just
have a look at his video if you want to
have like 16 17 more minutes of that
ending our voices torch it don't leave
ailing you know I hope you enjoyed the
enjoyed the video it was a bit much
today thanks for watching